it is a haunting and now familiar sight
refrigerator trucks to carry bodies
lined up outside hospitals in New York
this team at Long Island Jewish Medical
Center work in the morgue processing and
examining the victims of kovat 19 and
they're working seven days a week
I really admire our colleagues on the
front lines that are dealing with the
patients that are coming in with the
Cova 19 their triaging them they're
managing and they're treating them but I
think people also need to realize that
there's another front to this war and
that's the front with the dead it's not
just the sheer number of the dead
they're struggling with it's also trying
to find a new way of communicating with
relatives it's always working with hard
working with the families at this point
in time but even more so now when when
you know they're not able to see their
loved ones in their last moments they've
had to improvise to try and support the
bereaved offering them a chance to see
those they've lost using video calls
this time it was the FaceTime so I did
first let her see me explain you know
what she's going to see asking her if
it's okay that she's you know are you
able to see this you know because we
couldn't keep it the way we normally do
as far as you know having sheets and
there was a body bag and you're seeing
her face so that was difficult it must
be very surreal and distressing for a
family to have to look at their loved
one on FaceTime I'm not gonna lie I
great it was tough
you know it's if we could do at least
one small thing to make this hard time
for them a little bit easier that's what
we're gonna do and no matter how crazy
our day is and how much work we have to
get done we're gonna do our best for our
families that we're dealing with they're
their family more than three and a half
thousand people have died from the virus
in New York State carrying out
post-mortems is crucial to understanding
it and ultimately saving lives what
makes this one I think scary for all of
us is that we don't really know yet what
exactly it does to us or in us we think
and it's a fair assumption that this is
primarily along pathology you know they
come in with difficulty breathing
they're short of breath and you see the
need for ventilators so respiratory
pathology plays a very important role in
this disease but that may not be the
whole picture
Lisa normally manages the administrative
side of their work but there are so many
bodies she now has to help move them to
the three of us were outside and we just
collapsed on like a crate and we were
just done you know we're exhausted we're
physically exhausted we're mentally
exhausting New York is beset with death
the makeshift morgues a bleak reminder
of a city under strain